der weltweite energiebedarf nimmt immer
weiter zu bis zum jahr 2050 werden wir
doppelt so viel strom verbrauchen wie
heute und ein großteil der energie
erhalten wir immer noch aus fossilen
brennstoffen die uns irgendwann ausgehen
werden was wir gegen diese bedrohliche
entwicklung unternehmen können jetzt in
kriegs und science fiction und außerdem
könnte in an gewinnspiel eine
playstation 4 mit dem spiel gta 5 ein
iphone 6 plus und 100 euro geschenk
gutschein gewinnen
nähere infos dazu gibt es am ende des
videos photovoltaikanlagen kosten eine
menge geld sie neben viel platz weg und
erfüllen nur einen einzigen zweck für
viele private haushalte lohnt sich diese
investition immer seltener ein ehepaar
aus amerika möchten diesen problemen und
abschaffen und dabei ganz nebenbei die
straße neu erfinden solar roth ways
heißt das unternehmen das seit fünf
jahren an seinem produkt arbeitet und
bereits viele hochrangige unterstützer
gewonnen hat die idee intelligente
straßen die komplett mit solarzellen
bedeckt sind um strom zu produzieren
die solarzellen werden von einer dünnen
tampa glasschicht geschützt diese lässt
die sonnenenergie durch ist aber so
robust dass autos und sogar lkw auf ihr
fahren können anders als normales glas
soll die oberfläche genug grip haben
damit im notfall man stark bremsen kann
und rechtzeitig zum stehen kommt die
straße der zukunft halber noch viele
weitere funktionen auf lager zum
beispiel die straßenmarkierung besteht
aus led lampen diese können bei bedarf
schnell umprogrammiert werden um den
verkehr umzuleiten außerdem sind
drucksensoren in den panels verbaut
diese können erkennen ob sich zum
beispiel tiere oder andere hindernisse
auf der fahrbahn befinden und die
autofahrer verwarnt
ein weiteres feature ist die eingebaute
heizung schnee und eis sind im winter
eine große gefahr für autofahrer das
gestreute salz belastet die umwelt indem
die straße leicht über null grad celsius
gehalten wird bleiben eis und schnee gar
nicht erst darauf liegen
die straße soll außerdem viel platz für
unterirdische kanäle bieten dem strom
und internet ladung kann man so auch
schmelzwasser umleiten so dass die
fahrbahn immer trocken und befahrbar
bleibt
ein kühnes projekt für das das ehepaar
eine million us dollar auf indigo
veranschlagt hat indigo ist eine
crowdfunding plattform auf der sich
jeder mit einer idee vorstellen und ein
großes publikum erreichen kann
menschen wie du und ich die das projekt
dann mit einer beliebigen sim
unterstützen im fall von solar roth
wales waren es fast 50.000 unterstützer
die dem ehepaar inzwischen mehr als 2,2
millionen us dollar beigesteuert haben
das geld wird nun genutzt um das projekt
zur serienreife zu bringen
auch wenn du eine riesige menge an
problemen zu bewältigen ist bewegen wir
uns mit solchen ideen in die richtige
richtung das tolle an solarzellen ist
dass sie sich irgendwann amortisieren
also das geld das sie gekostet haben in
form von strom wieder einbringen
das dürfte bei soular rot weiß ungefähr
so nach 22 jahren der fall sein
hypothetisch könnten die usa drei mal
mehr strom erzeugen als sie benötigen
wenn jede öffentliche straße durch eine
dieser solar straßen ersetzt werden
würde
das klingt natürlich im ersten moment
super ist aber finanziell kaum machbar
da eine so umfangreiche investition mehr
geld beanspruchen würde als die usa
jährlich zu verfügung haben
wenn sich solar straßen wirklich
durchsetzen dann nur sehr langsam über
jahre wenn nicht jahrzehnte hinweg
trotzdem steckt ein riesiges potenzial
hinter der technologie vor kurzem wurde
in den niederlanden die weltweit erste
öffentliche solar straße öffnet dort in
der nähe von amsterdam wurde an rund 70
meter langer fahrradweg erbaut um zu
erforschen wie ertragreich solarzellen
wirklich sind dabei ist ein wichtiger
faktor dass die solarzellen in der
straße nicht wie auf dem hausdach
angewinkelt sind sondern flach auf dem
boden liegen
so kann die sonnenenergie über den tag
hinweg nicht optimal genutzt werden um
mal verliehen ungefähr so ein drittel
der energie die forscher möchten
außerdem erfahren welche auswirkungen
menschen haben die sich über die straße
bewegen der produzierte strom wird von
straßenlaternen und häusern in der
umgebung genutzt und wer jetzt denkt
dass das besonders viel strom ist der
ist schief gewickelt gerade einmal so
drei typische niederländische haushalte
können mit der 70 meter langen straße
versorgt werden
die nächsten zwei jahren soll der
fahrradweg weiter ausgebaut werden und
vielleicht ladestation für elektroautos
oder e-bikes bieten das projekt kostet
insgesamt drei millionen euro und wird
sich so voraussichtlich in fünf
bis 20 jahren gerechnet haben falls
keine schweren reparaturen an fahren
täglich nutzen rund 2000 fahrradfahrer
die solar straße und jetzt bin ich
natürlich besonders gespannt was ihr zu
dem thema zu sagen habt denkt ihr dass
wir in zukunft auf solar straßen
autofahren werden oder seht ihr einfach
noch zu viele probleme bei der umsetzung
die diskutiert ist wie immer mit mir in
den kommentaren alle infos zu dem
angekündigten gewinnspiel erzählt euch
alexy beck sie von dem kanal turn on das
video ist hier verlinkt oder auch in der
video beschreibung natürlich unten zu
finden abonniert doch den kanadiern und
wenn ihr schon mal da seid und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran